this video is a little bit different
in it i'm going to tell the story
a story that has to do with the library
it has to do with this book
but it also has to do with the research
the
scholarship the philosophical detective
work
or quite frankly the obsession that
resulted in this book
it resulted in a lot more this is just
the tip of the iceberg you might say
in my first encounter with the christian
philosophy debates that took place in
france in the 1930s
i had no idea that they comprised
something that might turn into a book
like this
i'd heard something about them because i
had done my dissertation on maurice
blondel who was one of the major players
in these debates one of the players who
actually has been
very much left out in the
english-speaking literature on the
christian philosophy debate so
my book i provided translation of quite
a few of the documents that that
he had actually not all of them though
only
about um two-thirds of
his pieces um i knew that there were
some other
french catholic figures who played a
role in it but i didn't really know
that much about it i knew i wanted to
translate maurice blondell
in part because only a few of his works
mostly early works have been translated
as a matter of fact that's still a
project that i'm interested in i'd run
into a young guy
named adrian papst
he was involved in the the radical
orthodoxy
movement he was studying at the
institute catalita perry
and he had an interest in maurice
blondel as well i ran into him at a
conference
on continental philosophy of religion
at the university of lancaster in 2000
well he sent me through the mail some
some pieces including this one the
account of the session of the society
frances de philosophy
when they talked about the notion of
christian philosophy when that was the
key issue he also sent me another piece
you can see his his fancy writing
the review neo scholastic
the philosophy and this is by blondel
and it's called poorly philosophy
antegra i didn't know about this piece
at the time
and i didn't know about uh blondel's
intervention in this
so i started um i got these in
2003
and i read them through i read the blown
down parts through i wasn't that
interested
in everybody else at first and then
after a while i started looking at it
more carefully and what i realized was
there was a really complex
debate going on where there were a
number of different positions being
staked out they didn't all agree with
each other
i knew about some of the figures like i
knew about ati angel song
i knew him from this book which i've
read before
and i knew him as a scholar of
medieval philosophy so for instance you
know this is his book on bonaventure
i also knew about jacques moritan i
didn't know much about emil
although he had written a history of
philosophy because i tended not to rely
on secondary sources
i didn't know about nan brunshvik very
much other than he had been
somewhere involved with blondel and he'd
been somewhere involved with merlot
and so i started doing research on this
and then it just started spiraling
i found reference after reference
shooting off in different directions and
i realized there was really something
here that was well worth investigating i
myself became captivated by it
and i thought you know nobody seems to
know much about this
uh why not well it's because
a lot of these things haven't been
translated into english
if they're not in english people assume
they're not important and if people
assume they're not
important they don't get translated into
english
so then my next stop was the lie around
2004
i started carrying on more research
and i found myself hitting the library
which is
where you see me now obviously this is
not exactly the same library because
most of my research was carried out
at the university of notre dame's
heshberg library at that time
i was living in indiana and i was
only about an hour and a half from the
notre dame library which is
an excellent library for the sort of
research i was carrying on
and the more that i went
and the more that i started researching
and the more
journals and books
and databases and bibliographies i
started going through
the more threads there were to work out
the more i had to
follow up with things and
i had no idea just how vast the
literature
that comprised the christian philosophy
debates actually was
i still don't actually have all of it in
hand
i don't think anybody does one of my
great goals
is to someday accumulate all of it at
least in photocopy or digitized form
so at this stage in the story
what happened was i knew that blondel
and brunchfig and jillson moritan these
people were involved
and i would keep on going to the same
the same floor the 13th floor in the
hesburgh library
and i would just take out an entire
decade of journals i started with the
review de metaphysique de morale
and the review and i would just take out
the entire
section and just pour through it and go
really from about 1925 through
all the way through 1940. and looked for
any sort of reference to christian
philosophy
after a while i started to realize i saw
patterns there were certain authors who
were publishing in certain journals
there were certain dialogues that were
taking place back and forth through
different
journal articles and sometimes it would
actually switch it would go from the
review to metaphysical edimaral to
be reviewed homies or from those to the
review neo-scholastic or it would spill
over into
etude philosophique and i started just
going through
like i said and looking through
journal after journal after journal
article after article
and at first i was only looking at
titles then i actually started reading
through them
and after i had exhausted the french
philosophical journals i started looking
for
references in italian and
german and spanish and
even you know in the english speaking
journals and i found
some here and there and then i came upon
a bibliography that really helped me out
and there's a whole long story there
in 2006 i had been going back and forth
to these libraries and by that time i'd
actually expanded it so i was no longer
just looking in philosophy
areas i'd actually found the area of the
the library that had all the theology
and the popular
religious journals and i was going
through those as well that's how i found
a lot of interesting
pieces in things like vianta lexuel
and uh la nouvelle revue de june and
i actually found a lot of unsuspected
works that are not actually part of a
bibliography
by some of the major authors in these
christian philosophy debates that just
hadn't been compiled by by digging
through these
anyway back to the story so in 2006
in the summer i had actually been
selected to be part of the erasmus
institute
faculty summer fellowship with with
aleister mcintyre which was focused on
practical rationality
and i was by far the most junior and you
might say
least decorated when it comes to
publications member of the
the fellowship group there were 10 of us
i think that i was in primarily because
mcintyre was intrigued by the fact that
i had done prison teaching but that's an
entire
different story while i was there i got
to stay at notre dame
for the period of the fellowship and we
were housed and fed
i had access to the library and so
every night instead of drinking or you
know
playing the banjo that i had brought
along i did some of that as well or just
convincing with the other
participants i was spending after dinner
probably a good three to four hours in
the library every single night
just digging through the the journals
the books
anything i could find that had to do
with with christian philosophy and
especially with these debates
one of the participants tobias hoffman
who was at catholic university of
america
he found a book by
an italian scholar that had a really
good bibliography for at least part of
the debates
and he found it gave it to me i started
looking through it and now i
really hit pay dirt and i started you
know finding more and more
i was photocopying piece after piece
after piece but even still with that
bogliolo didn't have that's the italian
scholar
he didn't have all the references in
there
i kept finding more and more and more i
would sit down and just go through year
after year of reviewtom east
i would go into a section of the library
where i thought there might be something
sort of like a prospector digging for
gold and you sift through a lot of
things
you find a lot of other interesting
things on the way too by the way
if you if you have a photocopy card it
can get very expensive as you
find things that tie in with other
projects but
the key thing was i kept finding pieces
that i could use that needed to become
part of the compiled
materials for the christian philosophy
debates and so my collection grew
and grew and grew and every time that i
came back from the library
back to my home in indiana i had another
two
three if it was a very good day maybe
four or five
articles that i could add to my growing
horde almost you might say i still
haven't actually read all of them
i've skimmed all of them and read
through
most of them but i haven't actually had
the time to sit down and go through each
of them
line by line oftentimes when i would
read through a piece i would find
interesting bibliographical references
which then would have to be tracked down
i'm showing you this just to give you an
impression
about how much literature we're actually
talking about and this does not actually
comprise
all of it these are all dossiers
that i have prepared for instance you
know here's brunchfig's contributions
uh louis paul courchette's contributions
later uh writings like jermaine grize
people who were involved tangentially in
the debates
much later scholars like tillette
correspondence between jill so and
mauritan and other people
um these are all photocopies
these are all the things that i found in
the libraries
carried down to the seventh floor or to
the
12th floor or the 11th floor the second
floor of notre dame's heshberg library
and photocopied bit by bit by bit
over years that gives you an idea of the
extent of my obsession
but it also gives you an extent of it
gives you an idea of the extent
of the the sheer subject by itself